[Music]
you must really like fishing mr.
president it's cold out here
sorry not anything to get out of DC from
how Mike I am selecting you for Secret
Service Director congratulations I'll
give it my best shot sir what is that
Laidback I'm coming to you coming at you
walking underwater camp
look I got you going under died deep
there's been an assassination attempt on
my fanny
you're being charged with the attempted
murder of the President of the United
States don't you see I'm being set up
you have a collect call from Mike
I've been getting death threats somebody
else behind us it wasn't me the
president's not safe then you're trying
to finish the job and I'm not gonna stop
until I prove who did this
[Music]
how did you find me I want security for
the president how you think dad I need
your help
I ain't gone away
you can't hide from us better don't
worry about finding me
don't find you
listen to me we're gonna make a move now
people are gonna fall not you
[Music]
you